a new lawsuit targets the Department of
Education for suspending rules that
would erase student debt for some
Americans 18 states and the District of
Columbia are suing the Education
Department and Secretary Betsy DeVos now
the lower rules would have protected
students of for-profit colleges that
engaged in misconduct the suit is led by
the Attorney General of Massachusetts it
seeks to reinstate the loan relief rules
finalized last year by the Obama
administration president Trump's
proposed budget reduces the Department
of Education funds by more than 13
percent it also aims to simplify and
consolidate student loan programs CBS
News business analyst Jill Schlesinger
is here with more chill good morning
good morning what do you make of all
this well you know these two rules went
into place if you recall after that
Corinthian College debacle this was a
for-profit college it went out of
business and the students there
basically said hey we are went through
classes we have no degree but we have
all this debt so they went after the
government to help them out so the two
rules do different things one is it says
to the these colleges you must actually
create an educational experience that
will allow these kids to get a job
gainfully employed it the other thing it
does is it gives the kids and ability to
go to the government and say hey I've
got a problem I need to renegotiate it I
think there was some fraud here those
two rules are on ice and a lot of these
people are left in limbo it doesn't
affect the 16,000 who were already in
process but anyone knew who wants to do
this cannot do so well the Department of
Education has released a statement that
says this the borrowed defense
regulations suffer from substantive and
procedural flaws that need to be
considered before imposing new burdens
on regulated parties that will come at a
cost of fourteen point nine billion
dollars in the next ten years so first
translate what that means and what do
you think the Trump administration plans
to do about the student loans well the
the issue on this is again that they
believe that there are problems with the
process by which people can go through
the the the questioning of why the loan
is out there there may be some feeling
on the administration's hands that they
say you know what maybe these kids knew
what they were getting into and they've
got buyer's remorse now so
there is some issue here around what the
administration plans to do the taxpayers
bail out a student loan program when
they went with a for-profit college so
the issue is that maybe the kids didn't
know exactly what they were getting what
was disclosed there's been some
predatory processes on some of these
for-profit colleges that really have
targeted some lower-income folks who
didn't really understand what they were
doing and remember because federal funds
are given to these plan to these
colleges they are subject to regulatory
oversight now look what's happening here
is the Trump administration really wants
to say we want to scrap what's going on
and look at what's happening they
haven't done so yet other things that
are happening that are really big and
part of this is another lawsuits going
on it's around the forgiveness program
if you work in the public sector there
are four individuals who are attorneys
who are looking at this and saying hey
we got Declassified in other words if
you work for a public sector company
institution you pay your payments for
ten years your loan will be forgiven
after 10 years these people got
reclassified they said you're not in the
program so the forgiveness program is
also under scrutiny this is a big deal
keep an eye on it student loans are a
enormous issue remaining and that
commercial Thanks 1.3 trillion dollars
all right thank you very much Jill
Schlesinger